Je vous ai dit trois choses l’année dernière.
Je vous ai dit que les statistiques mondiales
n’avaient pas été correctement mises à disposition.
À cause de cela, nous avons toujours la vieille mentalité
de pays en développements et industrialisés, ce qui est faux.
Et je vous ai dit que les graphiques animés peuvent faire la différence.
Les choses sont en train de changer.
Et aujourd’hui, sur la page d’accueil de la Division des Statistiques des Nations Unies,
il est dit : à partir du premier mai, accès complet aux bases de données.
(Applaudissements)
Et si je pouvais vous faire voir l’image sur l’écran.
Il est donc arrivé trois choses.
Les Nations Unies ont ouvert leurs bases de données statistiques,
et nous avons une nouvelle version du logiciel
qui fonctionne sur le net,
de sorte que vous n’avez plus à le télécharger,
Laissez-moi répéter ce que vous avez vu l’année dernière.
Les bulles sont les pays.
Ici vous avez le taux de fécondité (le nombre d’enfants par femme)
et là vous avez la durée de vie en années.
Voilà 1950... Celles-ci étaient les pays industrialisés,
celles-là étaient les pays en développement.
À l’époque, il y avait nous et eux.
Il y avait une très grande différence dans le monde.
Mais cela a changé, et plutôt dans le bon sens.
Voila ce qui est arrivé.
Vous voyez que la Chine est la grosse bulle rouge;
la bleue ici c'est l’Inde.
Je vais essayer d’être
un peu plus sérieux cette année pour vous montrer
comment les choses ont réellement changé.
C’est l’Afrique qui semble ressortir comme le problème dans ce coin, n’est-ce pas?
Toujours des familles nombreuses, et l’épidémie de VIH
a fait chuter les pays ainsi.
C’est plus ou moins ce que nous avons vu l’année dernière,
et voilà comment cela va continuer dans le futur.
Et je continue de parler. Comment est-ce possible?
Parce que voyez-vous, j'ai présenté des statiques qui n’existent pas.
Parce que nous sommes ici.
Est-il possible que cela arrive?
Je couvre toute ma vie ici, vous voyez?
Je m’attends à vivre 100 ans.
Et voici où nous en sommes aujourd’hui.
Maintenant, pourrions-nous plutôt regarder la situation économique mondiale?
J'aimerais la rapporter à la survie infantile.
On va inverser les axes:
ici il y a la mortalité infantile -- c’est à dire la survie --
quatre enfants qui meurent ici, 200 là.
Et sur cet axe, c’est le PIB par habitant.
Ça c'était en 2007.
Si je retourne dans le passé, j’ai ajouté des statistiques historiques --
on recule, on recule, on recule -- pas beaucoup de statistiques il y a 100 ans.
Quelques pays avaient quand même des statistiques.
On fouille dans les archives,
et là où nous sommes, en 1820,
seules l’Autriche et la Suède peuvent produire des données.
(Rires)
Mais ces pays étaient là, en bas, ils avaient 1000 dollars par personne et par an.
Ils perdaient un cinquième de leurs enfants avant la première année.
Alors voila comment ça se passe dans le monde, si on intègre le monde entier,
comment ils sont devenus progressivement de plus en plus riche,
et ils ajoutent des statistiques.
N’est-ce pas merveilleux quand ils obtiennent de nouvelles statistiques ?
Vous voyez l’importance que ça a ?
Ici, les enfants ne vivent pas plus longtemps.
Au siècle dernier, en 1870, ça allait mal pour les enfants en Europe,
parce que la plupart de ces statistiques sont européennes.
Ce n'est qu’à partir du début du siècle
que plus de 90% des enfants survivent la première année.
Voilà l’Inde qui monte, avec les premières données indiennes.
Ça ce sont les États-Unis qui s'éloignent ici, qui gagnent plus d’argent.
Et on va bientôt voir la Chine monter tout au bout dans l’angle.
Elle monte avec Mao Tsé-Tung qui apporte la santé,
pas trop la richesse.
Puis il meurt, ensuite Deng Xiaoping apporte l’argent,
elle se déplace là-bas dans ce coin.
Les bulles continuent de monter ici en haut
et voila à quoi ressemble le monde aujourd’hui.
(Applaudissements)
Regardons les États Unis.
Il y a une fonction dans le logiciel... Je peux dire au monde, “Reste où tu es”
Et je prends les États-Unis -- on veut conserver l'arrière-plan --
je le fais ressortir comme ça, et maintenant on remonte dans le temps.
Et on peut voir que les États-Unis
se déplacent à droite de la tendance générale.
Ils sont tout le temps du coté de l’argent.
En 1915, les États-Unis étaient voisins de l’Inde --
l’Inde contemporaine, d’aujourd’hui.
Cela veut dire que les États-Unis étaient plus riches,
mais qu'ils perdaient plus d’enfants que l’Inde aujourd’hui, proportionnellement.
Et regardez ici -- comparez avec les Philippines d’aujourd’hui.
Les Philippines aujourd’hui ont à peu près la même économie
que les États-Unis durant la Première Guerre Mondiale.
Mais il faut faire avancer les États-Unis pendant un bout de temps
avant de les voir atteindre le même niveau de santé
que les Philippines.
Autour de 1957, ici, la santé des États-Unis
est la même que celle des Philippines.
Et c’est le drame de ce monde que beaucoup considèrent globalisé,
qui est que l’Asie, les pays arabes, l’Amérique latine,
sont bien plus en avance en terme de santé, d’éducation,
de ressources humaines qu’elles ne le sont économiquement.
Il y a une divergence dans ce qui se passe aujourd’hui
dans les économies émergentes.
En ce moment, dans ces pays, les avantages sociaux,
le progrès social, avancent devant le progrès économique.
En 1957 -- les États-Unis avaient la même économie que le Chili de nos jours.
De combien de temps faut-il faire avancer les États-Unis
pour qu’ils aient le même niveau de santé que le Chili aujourd’hui ?
Je crois qu'il faut aller, là -- donc 2001, ou 2002 --
les États-Unis ont le même niveau de santé que le Chili.
Le Chili se rapproche !
D'ici quelques années, le Chili pourrait avoir une meilleure survie infantile
que les États-Unis.
C’est vraiment un changement, que vous ayez ce retard
d’à peu près 30, 40 ans de différence au niveau de la santé.
Derrière la santé il y a le niveau d’éducation.
Et il y a beaucoup de choses au niveau de l’infrastructure,
et les ressources humaines globales sont là.
Maintenant, on peut enlever ça
et je voudrais vous montrer la vitesse,
le taux de changement, avec quelle rapidité ils évoluent.
Et on revient en 1920, et je veux observer le Japon.
Je veux aussi observer la Suède et les États-Unis.
Je vais mettre en place une course ici
entre la Ford jaunâtre
la Toyota rouge en bas
et la Volvo brunâtre
(Rires)
Et c’est parti!!!
La Toyota prend un très mauvais départ, comme vous pouvez le voir,
et la Ford américaine fait du hors-piste là-bas.
La Volvo s’en tire plutôt bien.
Et c’est la guerre. La Toyota quitte sa trajectoire
et du coup la Toyota se trouve du coté Santé de la Suède --
Vous voyez ?
Et ils sont en train de dépasser la Suède,
et ils sont maintenant en meilleure santé que la Suède.
C’est le moment où j’ai vendu la Volvo et acheté la Toyota.
(Rires)
Et on peut voir que la vitesse d'évolution était énorme au Japon.
Ils se sont vraiment remis à niveau.
Cela change graduellement.
Il faut observer plusieurs générations pour le comprendre.
Laissez-moi vous montrer à ma manière mon histoire familiale --
nous avons créé ce graphe là.
Il y a les mêmes éléments, argent en bas et santé, vous voyez ?
Et là c’est ma famille.
Ça c'est la Suède en 1830, quand mon arrière arrière grand-mère est née.
La Suède était au niveau de la Sierra Leone aujourd’hui.
Et là c'est quand mon arrière grand-mère est née, 1863.
La Suède était comme le Mozambique.
Voilà la naissance de ma grand-mère, 1891.
Elle s’est occupée de moi enfant,
et donc je ne parle plus de statistique maintenant --
maintenant on parle de l’histoire de ma famille.
C’est là que je crois aux statistiques,
quand ce sont des statistiques approuvées par grand-maman.
(Rires)
Je pense que c’est le meilleur moyen de vérifier des statistiques historiques.
La Suède était comme le Ghana.
Il est intéressant de voir l’énorme variété
au sein de l’Afrique sub-saharienne.
Je vous l’ai dit l’année dernière, je vous le dis encore,
ma mère est née en Égypte, et moi... Qui suis-je?
Je suis le mexicain de la famille.
Et ma fille, elle est née au Chili,
la petite-fille est née à Singapour,
qui est maintenant le pays qui a la meilleure santé sur cette Terre.
Ils ont dépassé la Suède il y a deux, trois ans,
avec une meilleur survie infantile.
Mais le pays est très petit, vous savez.
Ils sont si proches de l’hôpital qu’on ne peut pas
les battre dans nos forêts.
(Rires)
Mais rendons hommage à Singapour.
Singapour est numéro un en ce moment.
Tout cela ressemble à une très belle histoire.
Mais ce n’est pas si évident, que ce soit une belle histoire.
Parce que je dois vous montrer une autre fonctionnalité.
Nous pouvons aussi faire en sorte que la couleur représente la variable –
et quel est mon choix ?
Les émissions de CO2, en tonnes par personne.
En 1962, les États-Unis émettaient 16 tonnes par personne.
La Chine en émettait 0.6,
l’Inde 0.32 tonnes par personne.
Que se passe-t-il lorsque nous avançons ?
Et bien, vous voyez la gentille histoire de l'obtention de la richesse,
et d'une meilleure santé...
tout le monde l'a fait au prix des émissions de CO2.
Il n’y a personne qui ne l’ait pas fait jusqu’à maintenant.
Et nous n’avons plus toutes les données mises à jour
car ce sont des données brûlantes de nos jours.
Et nous voici en 2001.
Lors de discussions auxquelles j’ai assisté avec des leaders mondiaux, vous savez,
beaucoup disent que maintenant, le problème ce sont les économies émergentes,
qu'elles produisent trop de CO2.
Le ministre de l’environnement indien a dit :
“Eh bien, c'est vous qui avez causé le problème.
Les pays de l’OCDE – les pays à haut revenus --
ce sont eux qui ont provoqué le changement climatique.
Mais nous vous pardonnons, car vous ne le saviez pas.
Mais à partir de maintenant, on compte par personne.
A partir de maintenant on compte par personne.
Et chacun est responsable de ses émissions par personne”
Cela vous montre vraiment que nous n’avons pas vu de progrès économique
et en matière de santé significatifs où que ce soit dans le monde
sans destruction du climat.
C’est vraiment cela qui doit être changé.
J’ai été critiqué pour vous avoir montré une image trop positive du monde,
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit le cas.
Le monde est un endroit plutôt en désordre.
Voici le “Dollar Street”.
Tout le monde vit dans cette rue.
Ce qu’ils gagnent ici -- le nombre qui correspond --
c'est le montant de ce qu’ils gagnent par jour.
Cette famille gagne environ un dollar par jour.
On remonte la rue par-là,
et on trouve une famille qui gagne autour de deux, trois dollars par jour.
Et on continue à s'éloigner -- on trouve le premier jardin de la rue,
et ils gagnent 10 à 50 dollars par jour.
Comment vivent-ils?
Si on regarde le lit, on peut voir
qu’ils dorment sur un tapis sur le sol.
Voila ce qu’est le seuil de pauvreté --
80% des revenus familiaux servent juste à couvrir les besoins en énergie,
et la nourriture du jour.
Voila deux à cinq dollars, il y a un lit.
Et là, il y a une chambre bien plus agréable, vous pouvez voir.
J’ai fait une conférence là-dessus pour IKEA,
ils ont immédiatement voulu voir le sofa ici.
(Rires)
Et voila le sofa, comment il apparaît ici.
Et ce qui est intéressant, quand on se balade dans cette photo panoramique,
c’est de voir la famille toujours en train de s’asseoir sur le sol,
même si il y a un sofa.
Si on regarde la cuisine, on peut voir que
la grande différence pour les femmes ne se fait pas entre 1 et 10 dollars.
Elle se fait au-delà, quand vous pouvez vraiment avoir
de bonnes conditions de travail dans la famille.
Et si vous voulez vraiment voir une différence,
regardez les toilettes.
Ça peut changer, ça peut changer.
Toutes ces photos et ces images viennent de l’Afrique,
et ça peut s’améliorer grandement.
Nous pouvons sortir de la pauvreté.
Mes propres recherches n’ont pas été sur ordinateur ou quoique ce soit du genre.
J’ai passé 20 ans à interroger des fermiers africains
qui étaient au bord de la famine.
Et ceci est le résultat des recherches sur les besoins des fermiers.
Ce qui est bien c'est qu’on ne voit pas
qui sont les chercheurs sur cette photo.
C’est dans ces cas-là que les recherches marchent pour les sociétés --
il faut vraiment vivre avec les gens.
Quand vous êtes pauvre, tout est une question de survie.
Il faut trouver de la nourriture.
Et ces deux jeunes fermières, ce ne sont que des jeunes filles --
parce que leur parents sont morts du VIH et du SIDA --
elles discutent avec un agronome diplômé.
C’est l’un des meilleurs agronomes au Malawi, Junatambe Kumbira,
et ils sont en train de discuter quelle sorte de manioc elles vont planter -
-- le meilleur convertisseur de soleil en nourriture que l’homme ait trouvé.
Et elles sont extrêmement avides d’avoir ces conseils,
et ce, pour survivre dans la pauvreté.
C’est un contexte.
Sortir de la pauvreté.
Les femmes nous ont dit une chose: “ Apportez-nous la technologie.
Nous haïssons ce mortier, nous restons debout des heures.
Apportez-nous une meule que nous puissions moudre notre farine,
ensuite nous pourrons payer le reste nous-mêmes.”
La technologie vous sortira de la pauvreté,
mais il y a besoin d’un marché pour sortir de la pauvreté.
Cette femme est très heureuse maintenant, en apportant ses produits au marché.
Mais elle est très reconnaissante de l’investissement public dans les écoles
afin qu’elle sache compter, et ne se fasse pas avoir une fois rendue au marché.
Elle veut que son enfant soit en bonne santé, pour qu'elle puisse aller au marché
et n’ait pas à rester à la maison.
Et elle veut l’infrastructure -- c’est bien avec une route pavée.
Le crédit est aussi un plus.
Les micro-crédits lui ont donné le vélo, vous savez.
Et des informations lui diront quand se rendre au marché, avec quels produits.
Vous pouvez le faire.
Mon expérience de 20 ans en Afrique c'est que
ce qui semble impossible est possible.
L’Afrique ne s’est pas mal débrouillée.
En 50 ans, ils sont passés d’une situation pré-médiévale
à une Europe très décente d’il y a 100 ans,
avec des états et nations fonctionnels.
Je dirais que dans le monde, c'est l’Afrique sub-saharienne qui s'est le mieux débrouillée
ces 50 dernières années.
Parce qu'on ne prend pas en compte d’où ils viennent.
C’est ce concept stupide de pays en développement
qui nous compare avec l’Argentine et le Mozambique 50 ans en arrière,
et qui dit que le Mozambique aujourd'hui est en retard.
Nous devons en apprendre un peu plus sur le monde.
J’ai un voisin qui connaît 200 sortes de vins.
Il connaît tout.
Il connaît le nom du raisin, la température et tout.
Je ne connais que deux sortes de vin -- rouge et blanc.
(Rires)
Mais mon voisin ne connaît que deux sortes de pays --
industrialisé et en développement.
Et j’en connais 200, je connais toutes les petites données.
Mais vous pouvez le faire.
(Applaudissements)
Mais je dois rester sérieux. Et comment on fait pour être sérieux ?
En faisant un PowerPoint, vous savez ?
(Rires)
Rendons hommage au pack Office, non?
C'est quoi ça, c'est quoi ça, qu'est-ce que je raconte ?
Je raconte qu’il y a beaucoup de dimensions de développement.
Tout le monde veut votre petit truc.
Si vous êtes dans le secteur des entreprises, vous aimez les micros-crédits.
Si vous vous battez dans une organisation non gouvernementale,
vous aimez l’égalité des sexes.
Ou si vous êtes un professeur, vous aimerez l’UNESCO, et ainsi de suite.
Au niveau mondial, nous devons avoir plus que notre petit truc.
Nous avons besoin de tout.
Toutes ces choses sont importantes pour le développement,
en particulier lorsque vous venez juste de sortir de la pauvreté
et que vous devez aller vers le bien-être.
Maintenant, ce à quoi il nous faut réfléchir
c'est : qu'est-ce qu'un but de développement,
et quels sont les moyens de développement ?
Je vais d’abord mettre des notes aux moyens les plus importants.
La croissance économique pour moi, en tant que professeur de santé publique,
est la chose la plus importante pour le développement,
car elle explique 80% de la survie.
La gouvernance. Avoir un gouvernement qui fonctionne --
c’est ce qui a sorti la Californie de la misère en 1850.
C’est le gouvernement qui a finalement fait fonctionner la loi.
L’éducation, les ressources humaines sont importantes.
La santé est importante aussi, mais pas tant que ça en tant que moyen.
L’environnement est important.
Les droits de l’Homme aussi sont importants, mais ils n’ont qu’une croix.
Maintenant, quels sont les buts ? Où voulons-nous aller ?
L'argent ne nous intéresse pas.
L’argent n’est pas un but.
C’est le meilleur moyen, mais je lui donne zéro en tant que but.
La gouvernance, eh bien, c’est marrant de voter dans un petit truc,
mais ce n’est pas un but.
Et aller à l’école, ce n’est pas un but, c’est un moyen.
Je donne deux points à la santé. Je veux dire que c’est bien d’être en bonne santé
-- surtout à mon âge -- vous pouvez vous tenir debout, vous êtes en bonne santé.
Et ça c’est bien, elle reçoit deux plus.
L’environnement est absolument essentiel.
Il ne restera rien pour les petits-enfants si vous ne le préservez pas.
Mais où sont les buts importants ?
Les droits de l’Homme, bien sûr.
Les droits de l’Homme sont le but,
mais ils ne sont pas très puissants comme moyen de se développer.
Et la culture. La culture est la chose la plus importante, je dirais,
car c’est ce qui amène la joie dans la vie.
C’est la valeur de la vie.
Donc ce qui semble impossible est possible.
Même les pays d’Afrique peuvent y arriver.
Et je vous ai montré la photo où ce qui semble impossible est possible.
Et souvenez vous, s’il-vous-plaît, souvenez-vous de mon principal message,
qui est le suivant: ce qui semble impossible est possible.
Nous pouvons avoir un monde bon.
Je vous ai montré les photos, je vous l’ai prouvé avec le Powerpoint,
et je pense que je vais aussi vous convaincre avec la culture.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Qu’on m'apporte mon épée !
Les avaleurs d'épée nous viennent de l’Inde ancienne.
C’est une forme d'expression culturelle qui pendant des millénaires
a inspiré les hommes à réfléchir au-delà de l’évidence.
(Rires)
Et je vais maintenant vous prouver que ce qui semble impossible est possible
en prenant cette pièce d’acier -- acier véritable --
ceci est une baïonnette de l’armée Suédoise, 1850,
la dernière année où nous avons eu une guerre.
Et elle est faite entièrement d’acier -- vous pouvez l’entendre.
Je vais prendre cette lame d’acier,
et la pousser au fond de mon corps de chair et de sang,
et vous prouver que ce qui semble impossible est possible.
Puis-je vous demander un moment de silence total?
(Applaudissements)